it's a job no one would envy we do a
broad spectrum of severe cleanups for
sure our r5 is probably an average joe's
10 on a severity chart no doubt about it
they walk into scenes few could ever
conceive uh what's the worst thing you
can imagine honestly is what I asked him
what's the worst thing you can imagine
and they'll tell me a shotgun suicide
I'll say okay yeah shotgun suicide now
the person hadn't been found for six
weeks
they lived in filth they were a junkie
they had an animal that was eating him
for six weeks that animal died and then
we get called that might be the worst
thing I've ever seen
I'm gonna be going through all the
papers looking for all the the job has
work hazards like no other dismembered
body parts toxic bodily fluids ooh
body soil I think people find a lot of
things difficult on jobs but primarily
is exactly what you would think
blood skull brain clumps of hair maggots
all the insects is very shocking for the
crime scene cleaners nausea is just part
of the job I have to get it done I mean
there's not much of a choice as my rap
on the line so I'm gonna get it done
even if I'm puking in my respirator
while I do it they face gross situations
with a black sense of humor you say
maggots I say money this is a job where
you can either deal with it or you can't
you have to be strong in mind I mean
most people think we're crass because
we'll joke about it and do you have to I
mean there's there are coping mechanisms
that you're equipped with and you either
cope or you melt even all of that
insulation this is a service few ones
and know about you until they need it
most have that tenant just see the
problem it's one of those where you
don't want to think about it you don't
want to know about it unless little
Johnny just blew his brains out your
living room and then you want us there
yesterday
four-year veteran Shawn Clarke faces a
daunting task a man who left in front of
a speeding train
Shawn's job is to rid the Train of every
piece of flesh every hair every drop of
body fluid he comes every inch of the
undercarriage looking for remains
apparently this is where our person dove
in front of the train so they do VIN
between two cars as they were traveling
about 50 miles an hour in between
stations and so there's a tendency for
people to explode when they get
underneath the Train and so there's
they'll be a lot of cast-off check this
coupler here body parts have a tendency
to get stuck in between them hands and
that sort of thing it's not uncommon to
find actual pieces of finger and ears
lips with nose and mustache on them